[Music]
today we are celebrating the fourth of
July and we're offensive today for the
July 4th holiday I think I should have
chose some other decorations I think
we're gonna make this cake for as a five
layer cake we are making some red white
and blue cupcakes and some surprise
cakes no you didn't tell me anything you
just said hey put on our red shirt pull
back my shirt is missing okay let me
show you my spine cover it okay
Omega trembles the world we're just
living in it okay first things first
we're gonna make one of our case if I
don't look at it
nothing bad so what we're doing here is
you're making a simple I'm somewhat
about that main ensuring line you know
how many times I've done this enough to
know why do I let her do the egg whites
no I need it why it's not yellow shoot
but perfect I am a professional good for
you just rubbing it oh no a little bit
Jill of America yeah this cupcake
dispenser thing is probably the coolest
thing ever I bought it so long ago and I
never energies mmm tastes like freedom
315 dildo really Oh breathe this oven to
350 which I should have done probably
forever and ago you put them all in I'm
trying to freaking prepare merica I let
them all cool off nicely so these are
our America cakes are you okay oh yeah
now we're gonna let it cool and then
we're gonna decorate welcome to America
kids we're testing our healthcare is it
- I think it's a nice hole is it good
you may notice that we are on the floor
yes but I have wax paper down and it is
a freshly cleaned floor oh my god icing
everywhere I'm just gonna lightly dump
no yeah so sorry I don't know how to do
anything
Wow oh this is like basically cue colors
cuz it's not mixed well wait I want you
to cut that innocent pills
no I how so fluffy oh it's a rather as a
pink I don't think I was associate video
I'm sorry at the bottom because I can
start up over the bottom now I hit Oh
that looks stupid all right guys now
it's time for the super special surprise
looks nice this is way too much icing oh
my god oh my god I'm not lazy it's like
we have to just put a little bit because
it just has to seal it together these
are a lot of icing on here we should
shave off this topic okay I'm just gonna
shave this off Wow what cut my skin
surprise surprise watch this
that wasn't the problem what was the
problem
yeah that's not right no I've only seen
better you Arthur Stuart is somewhere
waters you next video
crying all right oh the problem here is
the blue should shave a little bit off
mmm I'm so sick just looking at this
it's all gonna look perfect when we cut
the cake in half what happened here Oh
some things are there turns on oh I
think they look oh that's my daughter
yeah she won't keep touching my god
there's icing on it it's almost like a
bouquet
[Music]
now the real test is cutting it
if I stand all the way back here the
cake looks really good
[Music]
it's gonna look just like it said on
Pinterest Teddy yeah I mean all right oh
wow okay just set it somewhere there it
is
[Applause]
I wanted this cake to be perfect I
thought I honestly thought we could do
this I lost my phone surprise I think
I'm about to bake my phone inside of
those fingers watching huge thank you to
data for helping out this video
well thanks for watching we now have to
clean up now I think we might need to
hire a system like it hazmat cam oh my
god our cake came out perfectly zoom in
so you think it's honor yeah who are
there I shut my eyes trying not to speak
Richenda I smell your brain not
listening but I still yeah
[Music]